imagine a world where we get what we all
deserve a good day nothing seems much
different the world is much the same as
it is now people do the same sorts of
things have much the same joys and pains
they're born they grow up they work they
play have families love argue enjoy
their brief time on earth and die it's
just that if you go to the outskirts of
any town there's a new facility there it
looks like a Medical Center it is in a
way a world design building with nice
landscaping and a free car park if you
go inside you'll discover what's going
on
the receptionist can explain there are
leaflets too everything is well ordered
and calm doctors psychologists
counselors and nurses work here the so
tutors specialists lawyers this is the
good death center provided on the
National Health Service those who don't
want to descend into the indignity of
extreme dementia or doubt the ability of
palliative care to ease the exit from
life will come here when the time is
right they'll choose the moments of
their own deaths most of us have a death
plan and a living will now it's a great
comfort to know that the option exists
if the going gets too tough we've heard
euthanasia for pets for a very long time
but before the good death centers we
forced our friends and relatives to
endure months and sometimes years of
agony and indignity against their will
for what they now seems so cruel so
unnecessary so pointless
of course there are safeguards no one
gets to use the facility without
thorough psychological examination and
counseling this choice is only for the
sound of mind and those who have
demonstrated a genuine desire to die by
these means you need a good reason such
as a painful terminal illness or the
first signs of dementia consent has to
be informed life is much better now
it's reassuring to know you don't have
to endure it even when you've lost the
power to take your own life
I have my own death plan if I don't die
my sleep I expect to die in a good death
center it's a comforting thought you
should think about it